look at that horse the bushy tail the
big teeth
hey we're Grizz folk and these are our
favorite YouTube videos hey my name is
Adam and I sing in the band called Grizz
Volk and my favorite video is reporter
turns ghetto in three seconds what
really happened on that Thursday here in
Augusta high school that led to Chris
Wood's death and I found it funny
because he is very proper and he's
obviously in the south where there's
bugs flying in her face and in your
mouth and her nose and he gets like
completely livid I'm done
contrast step down hit flat in my mouth
yep okay see Tyler oh good god this
country mother hi my name is Fredrick
can't play guitar and my favorite
youtube clip is IKEA Swedish midsummer
fest it's a German take on kinda how we
celebrate the midsummer tradition in
Sweden to kind of showcase how we drink
the moonshine and eat raw fish and how
we dance till the Sun goes up
[Music]
hi I'm Bill I play drums in Griswold and
my favorite YouTube video is talking
beaver on the highway basically just a
beaver who welcomes speeding cars into
Canada by saying welcome to Canada over
and over again it was right before we
went on tour in Canada actually so it
became a kind of a running joke we kept
repeating that phrase welcome to Canada
hi my name is Sebastian I play keys and
Grizz folk my favorite YouTube clip is
the German commercial this is a German
Coast Guard the US Navy free they're
like Mayday Mayday
we're sinking we're sinking what are you
thinking about
hey I'm Brenda and I play bass in Grizz
folk my favorite video on the web it's
been around for a while it's called look
at that horse sure around the picture
the horse I showed you earlier well here
it is blown up there's a big horse your
mistakes a butterfly for a horse it's
hard to do look at that horse the bushy
tail the big teeth the hooves I love
watching a guy backpedal okay my
producer Tara Cates just told me this
isn't a horse it's a butterfly and then
he's like but maybe it's a moth yeah
actually it may in fact be a moth thanks
for watching
us look at videos online
[Music]
[Applause]